la tente a été longue la tension était
palpable
répétées de l'opposition et des semaines
d'obstruction libérales le bras droit de
Justin Trudeau témoigne les élections de
2019 et 2021 ce sont déroulés librement
et équitablesment les députés
d'opposition l'attendaient de pied ferme
au coeur des interrogations que savaient
le bureau du Premier ministre et à quel
moment la télé vous est-ce que vous avez
vu ces documents ici il y a de
l'information que qu'elle garde
à l'intérieur du cabinet et qui n'est
pas divulgué à soi des ministres voire
même le Premier ministre
je ne cache rien au Premier ministre
assure que littleford mais pour le reste
de son témoignage la chef de cabinet se
réfugie souvent derrière son devoir de
réserve pour des raisons de sécurité
nationale
n'empêche quelques heures à peine avant
son témoignage de nouveau document ont
fait surface on y apprend que Justin
Trudeau et ses ministres ont reçu 31
séances d'informations sur l'ingérence
étrangère depuis 2018
l'opposition très séance depuis 2018 une
document qu'on a reçu ce matin on les on
les aura seul la dernière minute alors
qu'on aurait pu les recevoir d'avance
c'est un manque de transparence de
remettre cette liste là à la dernière
minute au comité
après deux heures et demie de témoignage
parfois tendus parfois évasif quai
littleford semble avoir le sentiment du
devoir accompli les députés de position
eu déplorent des réponses vagues et
incomplètes le gouvernement continue
encore aujourd'hui son opération de
camouflage on ne cache rien au Premier
ministre donc on sait qu'il a
l'information la question qui reste
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il fait avec
l'information et quels sont les actions
qui sont prises par la suite les parties
de position restent donc sur leurs fins
malgré un témoignage qu'il réclamait
eux-mêmes à grand cri un manque de
transparence du gouvernement selon eux
qui démontre plus jamais la nécessité
d'une enquête publique ici Christian
Noël Radio-Canada Ottawa